welcome to this video playing dubby
Gabby no slack ok calc on f3 then the
fantasy variation and done I keep
forgetting what I have what I had
recommended in my in my serious for the
SEC Bishop e3 really yeah isn't this
cool I'm just many possibilities you
would never imagine them being possible
if I take all be 292 yeah maybe but ok
let's let's use this queen or v6 for
playing e5 system the the main point
anyway to get in five plate quickly
interesting ok well you can take my
forgot about this one if I get the check
though what is it jack dancin Wow and
they said and this is the play playing
this in the morning it's not much fun
III I can play night just playing
everything instantly this is cool so
night takes d5
I know it looks completely wacky but ok
95 I take on d2 and win okay this is
good if it takes with the night on III I
can maybe even Queen deform but at least
like I take III and take beach weather
should be good really not sure what else
is going to do yeah still night takes
III probably okay if you take sorry
three with the night is Queen D for at
least 24 but at least his God night
takes d5 and trying to play for
development so I prefer that and then we
take on won't be too right at least he
doesn't have an obvious move now I hope
maybe 90 for something like that yeah
okay may I need to get developed rugby
one yeah I need to get developed this is
certainly true but I think I should
focus on the King side let's play keys
Bishop e7 and castles you know me of
course he has not done much regard for
material suspect about a 2 by taking a 2
is not much not much fun I think just
this is this is better attacking the
bishop and getting Jack getting back
this way okay ma'am I go just to see 7
now maybe to d5 I let's go 25
yeah it's always if you if you're
already if you've sacrificed stuff and
it's always easy you can still have that
you can still throw more wood into the
fire it doesn't matter really mikey is
just sucking stuff it doesn't matter
anymore and he's got he's got some
compensation I mean it's two pawns but
so I've moved my queen so often but wow
it looks like a very sophisticated way
to play Queen on a one well I'll just
get my pieces out Bishop f5 if he moves
the rock so I can even consider to take
here on 96 maybe I should do that yeah
why not at least you cannot castle now
just take the tube now let's develop
95-93 yeah now it's got no compensation
at all I'm just two boards up probably
with the better position even good rugby
one look be one now just two to trade
things yeah maybe I had had something
better even this doesn't feel like I
played the best possible more spoon yeah
I should have more he really
yeah but it's it is it is a fine
position i'm taking this bishop so I'm
gaining some time if he goes to f2 I
even have rugby too yeah okay this is
this is okay nothing too yeah nothing to
worry about ready
I don't really see move not not a good
one the only slight issue is that i am a
bit bit vulnerable on the background not
excessively so but it sets a factor ok
just ya come on let's make some some
loot for the king bishop c2 to trade
maybe
just to have six oh wait the rook is
saying the look at night is singing oh
don't tell me how to endure the PCM
yeah it seems like I'm just blend I've
just blended apiece yeah this is also
the only way to ever not win this game
blundering a whole the whole piece ah
what the heck let's try to get rid of
pawns
it's got the right colored bishop this
is not very helpful check time warning
check yeah check black resigned yeah
well this happens if you just blend the
whole piece I mean the whole game was
basically a joke I was just giving away
points for nothing and then I just
blended this piece you have no way to I
can just take f2 why don't I take care
to I mean it's still a big blunder to
allow that but I mean to allow the
double attack but Luke f2 is just a
phone yeah this you can continue but he
can check check when the loop here
didn't see it just playing on time here
not looking candy good moves yeah the
opening is just unplayable I think I
mean it's just not not looking at all
around here check it looks like a like
is in excellent shape I'm just one point
up and this one was two points check for
no compensation whatsoever check ya
Queen a1 and stuff yeah okay but if you
blunder piece it doesn't help when the
really bad news can be
a bigger problem than then 20 subpar
ones by the opponent all right thanks
for watching